Donald Trump is punching back on all of
the FBI doj probes and raids into his
d-class is his classified documents they
argue which presented a threat to the
security of the United States and it was
they probably had the nuclear codes and
Trump almost killed us all because of
his closet at Mar-A-Lago Trump is
arguing
that it is not only did he not have the
classified material
not only did he not mishandle classified
material
Trump is arguing that he could
declassify material simply by thinking
about it
is there a process what was your process
today it doesn't have to be a process as
I understand it and you know there's
different people say different things
but as I understand there doesn't have
to be if you're the president of the
United States you could declassify just
by saying it's Declassified even by
thinking about it because you're sending
it to Mar-A-Lago or to wherever you're
sending it and there doesn't have to be
a process there can be a process but
there doesn't have to be you're the
president you make that decision so when
you send it it's Declassified we I
Declassified everything now I
Declassified things and we were having a
lot of problems with Nara you know Nara
is a radical left group of people
running that thing and when you send
documents over there I would say there's
a very good chance that a lot of those
documents will never be seen again
there's also a lot of speculation
because of what they did the severity of
the FBI coming in raiding Mar-A-Lago
were they looking for the Hillary
Clinton emails that were deleted but
they are around someplace so Trump is
saying he's making a good observation
he's saying they obviously didn't go
after Hillary this way and Hillary had
not only did she have more urgent
documents that were contemporary
documents they were documents while she
was Secretary of State not documents
from the past when she was in office as
was the case with Trump but furthermore
he's saying Hillary did not have this
ultimate right to declassify stuff and I
as president did and I didn't have to
follow a procedure and I could
declassify it with a magic wand I could
declassify it by saying these are
Declassified I could declassify
documents simply by thinking these
documents are Declassified
and so what people are going to hear is
ah there's Trump's hyperbole again
there's Mr Trump Mr exaggerator
he's right
he's right
no he has this caveat here he says look
different people have different opinions
and that's true the reason it's still
something of an open debate is because
this has never been brought up before no
one no doj has ever had the audacity
to go after a former president for
mishandling classified documents plenty
of presidents have taken documents from
the White House
most if not all of the modern presidents
have done that doj has never gone after
them and in part this might be because
of the strange historical circumstance
that Trump is not just the former
president he's the current top political
rival to the incumbent president who has
all but said that he's running for
president in 2024. so yes it's a sort of
open question but the answer to that
it's again it's that the Liberals taking
this tiny little grain of almost tiny
little bit of Truth and then
constructing a big lie around it
the answer to that question obviously is
that Trump is right
of course the president can declassify
whatever he wants whenever and however
he wants to do it
otherwise you you have a kind of
inversion of the Constitutional order
otherwise
the president is then
required to get the permission of some
random bureaucrat at the doj
and that is not how our system works
it's certainly not how our system is
supposed to work
the president is not supposed to be
responsible and accountable to some
middling careerist employee at one of
his own agencies in the executive branch
that's insane
of course the president has to have
ultimate declassification Authority
right now head on over to expressvpn.com
Michael Knowles show big Tech is more
powerful than most countries are they
profit by exploiting your personal data
it is time to put a layer of protection
between your online activity and big
Tech that is why I use expressvpn think
about how much of your life is on the
internet all of that information out
there every site you visit every video
you watch every message you send gets
tracked and data mined when you run
expressvpn on your device the software
hides your IP address something the big
Tech can use to personally identify you
so expressvpn makes your activity much
much harder to trace and sell to
advertisers expressvpn also encrypts 100
of your internet data to keep you safe
from hackers and eavesdroppers on your
network what I like most about
expressvpn super easy to use even I can
use it you download the app to your
phone or computer you tap one button
boom you're done expressvpn does all of
this without slowing your connection
that's why it's the number one rated VPN
service by techradar The Verge and
countless Others Stop handing over those
data to Big Tech
protect yourself with the VPN that I
trust to keep me safe online that's
expressvpn go to expressvpn.com
michaelknowles show to get three extra
months for free
this is just a political hit job on
Trump it's not the only one we mentioned
earlier this week that Leticia James the
Democrat AG in New York who ran for
office on a campaign of taking down
Donald Trump Leticia James is now
bringing suit against Trump for some
fraud in his businesses and she's saying
that Donald Trump exaggerated his wealth
wow breaking news stop the presses
Donald Trump may have at some point or
another exaggerated a little bit
particularly about his health wow no one
ever saw that one coming of course they
did that's part of the guy's whole brand
and even Bill Barr Trump's former
Attorney General who now they seem to
have a pretty Frosty relationship bar
has been very critical of trump at times
Bill Barr has even raised the prospect
that Trump may have broken some law with
the classified documents even Bill Barr
is coming out and saying this probe in
New York this is a total political hit
job
what ultimately persuades me that this
is a political hit job is uh she grossly
overreaches when she tries to drag the
children into the this yes they've had
roles in the business but this was his
personal financial statement it was
prepared by the CFO uh accounting firms
were involved in it the children aren't
going to know the details of that and be
able and nor are they expected in the
real world to do their own due diligence
and have it you know reviewed
independently and so uh this this to me
looks like gross overreach which I think
is going to end up backfiring on them
because I think it will make people
sympathetic for Trump that this is
another example of people piling on
because of trump derangements from this
you know this strong desire to you know
to to punish him
so Bill Barr who everyone knows doesn't
exactly love Donald Trump he's saying
this is so ridiculous and of course I've
been saying this for many months now
it is a it is a prosecution in search of
a crime in so many levels going after
Trump at the federal level because of
the election claims going after Trump at
the state level because of the election
claims the New York attorney general
looking into the Trump organization and
Trump's business dealings the FBI rating
Mar-A-Lago over the classified documents
it's all just BS it's a political hit
job to attack Donald Trump because the
libs think that he is the top prospect
in 2024 but there is actually some
question about that now there is a crazy
new number out of Florida a new poll
finds that since January Republicans in
Florida
have significantly changed their
presidential preference
and and Ron DeSantis even Rhonda Santos
the governor of Florida was trailing
Trump in Florida pretty significantly
now he's flipped that now DeSantis is
leading Trump in Florida for president
2024.
by the same margin that Trump had been
leading DeSantis at the beginning of the
year this according to a USA Today
Suffolk University poll on top of that
DeSantis has raised
177.4 million dollars that's more than
any other governor in history and he's
giving a lot of it away he's currying
favor with lots of other Republican
candidates to help them win around the
country
again I still think today if the primary
were held today Trump would most likely
blow it out of the water that's still
where most of the numbers are but the
question has been recently can there be
movement
DeSantis you know he's he's running he's
in the National media all the time is he
does he have the oomph to overtake
Donald Trump this is the very first time
and granted it's it's into Santa's
estate but this is the very first time
that you're seeing this kind of movement
where people might be scratching their
heads and saying wow even if Donald
Trump runs could someone like a Ronda
santis make a credible play for
president and beat him there are a lot
of people who are saying like hey maybe
I'll run I'm going to run even if Trump
runs Pompeo Nikki Haley is doing that
Rhonda Santos has been a little more
subtly suggesting that and going around
and raising money other candidates too
and it's probably BS
probably people are are not going to run
if Trump runs
but if you're getting numbers like this
and if DeSantis sees this kind of
movement in a few other states you might
get an actual Primary in 2024. I'm so
glad you like that clip now you gotta
ring that Bell Smash It bang it bop it
pop it we'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you